good afternoon a woman has died after
being injured in a crush at a concert at
Brixton Academy in South London on
Thursday police have named her as
Rebecca ikumelo who was 33 Antrim newham
in East London to our correspondent at
Katie Spencer who's following
developments and Rebecca Katie was one
of three women who were critically
injured yeah we
were the three women were in a critical
condition but today we have had an
update from the police confirming that
one of those women has died and naming
her as 33 year old Rebecca ikomelo that
we've had so much footage that's emerged
from what happened on Thursday night
outside of Brixton Academy footage of
the pushing of the crowds of the
freezing conditions and just how scary
it had become for people that were
caught up in that crash this all took
place during a gig for the afrobeat
singer asharkey he was on the third
night of three concerts that were taking
place sold out concerts but over a
thousand people it would seem had turned
up outside of there in the hopes of
getting into the Britain Academy to see
the singer now the singer within the
last hour has put out a statement as
well
really saying that he he is completely
devastated by what's happening saying
what's happened saying I am devastated
by the news that Rebecca ikamelo who was
in a critical condition since Thursday
has sadly passed away my sincerest
condolences to her loved ones at this
time let us please keep her family in
our prayers I've spoken to them and will
continue to do so I'm overwhelmed with
grief and could never have imagined
anything like this happening and he goes
on to say in that statement as well that
he's waiting to still be briefed from
the management team of the britsman
academy and from police as well into
exactly what went wrong that night and
of course an urgent investigation is now
underway because as you say two other
women remain in a critical condition a
21 year old and a 23 year old so police
currently launching this investigation
to try to figure out exactly what went
wrong on Thursday night
all right Katie thank you for updating
us Katie Spencer there